wow that is a lot of crazy amber mildred
roofing come on out here this is
pennywise behavior
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
green came under fire this week after a
video surfaced of her verbally harassing
representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez's staff back in 2019
before green was in congress accompanied
by a few friends greene yelled at
ocasio-cortez's staff through the mail
slot in her office door and dared the
congresswoman to come out and face her
see for yourself alexandria
ocasio-cortez i'm an american citizen i
pay your salary through the taxes that
you collect from me through the irs you
need to stop being a baby and stop
locking your door and come out and face
the american citizens that you serve if
you want to be a big girl you need to
get rid of your diaper and come out and
be able to talk to the american citizens
instead of us having to use a flap guess
what
you can't stand there forever
can you come out and play
wow
that is truly terrifying
hey amber
what is that hey amber ruffin
i uh i think it's coming from the mail
slot
amber mildred roofing come on out here
oh my god it's marjorie taylor green
marjorie i am not coming out there why
not
because i'm pretty sure you're gonna try
to murder me i am a peacock subscriber i
pay your salary you pay peacock's
monthly subscription fee
well no i have the free version all
right well you need to stop being a baby
and stop locking your door and come on
out and face your viewers i don't want
to why not i'm worried that if i go out
there things will get crazy oh baby if
i'm here things are already crazy come
on
come on out or let me in i just want to
talk oh yuck i am not coming out and you
sound like a character from the purge
that's not nice why are you bullying me
you're a bully i'm not bullying you
you're shouting at me through a mail
slot on my door it's unsettling this is
pennywise behavior
come on
you have to talk to me
face to face not through this little
flap no i don't have to talk to anybody
but i'm such a fan oh yeah if you're
such a fan name one sketch on this show
when i um
uh
mean tweets it's not even close look
marjorie it doesn't matter what you say
i'm not coming out there and you are
definitely not coming in here if you
want to be a big girl you need to get
rid of your diaper come out from that
desk and talk to me i don't wear a
diaper you wear a diaper help help she's
bullying me help aren't you a congress
person don't you have a job to do
yes
but i
i don't understand what it is no one
ever explained it to me
okay well you're a united states
congressperson your job is to represent
the constituents from your district and
to introduce and vote for legislation
that serves their best interests
so
no harassing people
no that's not part of your job so
i should probably go get to work yeah
that would be great
okay
hi amber
thanks
for being such a snowflake
oh no marjorie taylor green everybody
we'll be right back with more of the
amber ruffin show and i'm watching you
amber roofing okay republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor green was
back in the news this week you may
remember that the last time we checked
in with marjorie taylor green she was
shouting at representative alexandra
ocasio-cortez
through the mail slot on her office door
look alexandria ocasio-cortez i'm an
american citizen i pay your salary
through the taxes that you collect from
me through the irs you need to get rid
of your diaper and come out and be able
to talk to the american citizens instead
of having to use a flap
yikes
well last week a new video emerged of
taylor green yelling telling a bunch of
supporters at a fundraiser what they
should do if a government volunteer
comes to their door to promote vaccines
and one more thing on that you lucky
people here in alabama might get a knock
on your door because i hear alabama
might be one of the most unvaccinated
states in the nation
well joe biden wants to come talk to you
guys
he's going to be sending one of his
police state friends to your front door
well what they don't know is in the
south we all love our second amendment
[Music]
and we're not real rights on strangers
showing up on our front door are we
they might not like the welcome they get
wow that is a lot of crazy hey amber
amber roofing oh crap what is it
marjorie taylor green is at the door
i'm back
[Music]
get rid of your diaper and come on out
and talk to me marjorie taylor green you
get away from my door why
it's my right as a taxpayer to shout at
you you pay taxes
not if i can help it
you are the worst get out of here well
if you want me to leave so bad why don't
you just send one of your police state
friends to come and make me
i don't have any police state friends
also wait are you pro-police or
anti-police
stop bullying me i'm not bullying you
yes you are asking follow-up questions
is the worst kind of bullying i'm gonna
call 9-1-1 but then the police state
will show up oh don't use your liberal
mind tricks on me
come out and play
no and you have got to get away from my
door oh oh i get it
so you can come to my door and force me
to get a vaccine but i can't come to
your door and wave a little pistol
through the mail slot
oh no my gun
you cannot do that yes i can it's my
second amendment right oh ow quit
bumping me it's my turn
no it's not is there somebody else back
there with you
yes there is
hello amber it's me
handsome relatable bad boy next door
matt gates
no and handsome was the wrong word and i
i don't i don't want to talk to you
either why not
i'm just a wealthy successful sociopath
who's being investigated by the police
for several horrific crimes you just
described the plot of american psycho
oh you have me at american baby
look amber we actually agree on a lot
more than we disagree on oh yeah like
what
whoa
was that a follow-up question oh she
loves to do that bullying bullying
bullying
okay all right enough look you two don't
have anything better to do than harass
me at my job oh well
not really i got kicked off all my
committee assignments for being a freak
and all my closest friends are either in
custody or at sleepaway camp
so yeah
this is pretty much all we have to do
today well as long as you're in the
building i heard they're giving away
free vaccines in the lobby whoa look at
the time
get around bye
i had a feeling that would work yeah
yeah you know it worked it did
she should be careful those things are
dangerous guns
no her nails republican representative
marjorie taylor green was in the news
again this week but this time it wasn't
for shouting at representative
alexandria ocasio-cortez through the
mail slot of her office store remember
that we do
alexandria ocagio cortez i'm an american
citizen i pay your salary through the
taxes that you collect from me through
the irs you need to get rid of your
diaper and come out and be able to talk
to the american citizens instead of just
having to use a flap
very chill
now this time marjorie taylor green is
in hot water after a video emerged
showing her leaving the white house in
late december 2020. the video seems to
contradict her claims that she had
nothing to do with planning the january
6th attack on the capitol check it out
just finished with our meetings here at
the white house this afternoon we got
had a great planning session for our
january 6 objection we aren't going to
let this election be stolen by joe biden
and the democrats president trump won by
a landslide
well
that seems pretty cut and dry amber
amber roofing god damn it what is it
marjorie taylor green is at the door
trick or treat smell my feet give me
something dumb to tweet marjorie taylor
green you get away from my door you
can't make me it's halloween the only
night of the year where i can legally
shout through mail slots
oh so you're in costume right now what
are you dressed up as a functioning
adult person
what are you dressed as a snowflake
marjorie you are being very scary well
mission accomplished now give me some
candy corn
candy corn who would ever ask for candy
corn someone who doesn't understand the
difference between good and bad don't
let me in there amber elephant no way oh
please please there's a bunch of tiny
socialists out here
how can you tell that they're socialists
because they're asking for handouts
those are trick-or-treaters
help help there's a tiny iron man coming
this way and i think he wants universal
healthcare marjorie be honest did you
help plan the january 6th riots no
comment
when the protesters stormed the capitol
did you high-five them no comment
can you answer any questions about the
insurrection
let me check with my lawyers
send
oh
well what did they say they said lose
this number okay
marjorie don't you have work to do
not really at this point shouting awful
things at people is pretty much my
full-time job so you have nowhere else
to be that's right i guess i'll just
have to stay here forever
oh no sorry marjorie not happening
i'm on it
melting what a word
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you